it has come to my attention that i
forgot to acknowledge a very important
holiday yesterday
it is a holiday that commemorates the
life of one of the most important and
admired americans ever to live
a man who helped to transform our
country into the place that we live in
today
i'm speaking of course
about george floyd who joe biden
believes left a far more important
impact on our nation
than other lesser figures such as
i don't know martin luther king
but even dr king's assassination did not
have the worldwide impact
that george floyd's
death did
joe biden commemorated the life of
martin luther king by discussing how
much less he meant to the world than did
an unrepentant violent career criminal
who died resisting arrest while high on
a fatal dose of drugs
and the saddest part is
he's probably right
martin luther king may have had a dream
but joe biden has a nightmare joe biden
says george floyd left a greater impact
on america than martin luther king
that's probably true
that's probably true right i know that
conservatives are dunking on joe biden
right now and attacking him and how
offensive is this and how terrible
but joe biden didn't say that george
floyd was a better person than martin
luther king
he said that he left a greater impact on
the world not even just america but on
the whole wide world and that might be
true
martin luther king
did help to shape the world transformed
the world in many ways
but
but george floyd may have transformed
the world
much more
and whereas the legacy of martin luther
king is
hotly debated and the leftists try to
appropriate him and the conservatives
try to appropriate him and the democrats
try to appropriate him and the
republicans try to appropriate him and
the leftists point to the many things
that martin luther king said that
sounded sort of socialistic or sort of
leftist and the conservatives point to
the i have a dream speech in particular
where you shouldn't judge people based
on your race and
regardless of of
exactly who can grab martin luther
king's legacy they point to the i'm on a
i've been to the mountaintop speech this
kind of very
deep christian religious rhetoric that
he infused in his speeches regardless
the blm version of america seems to be
winning right now
the blm version of america which says we
most certainly should judge people on
the basis of their race we should
give
black people and other non-white people
special privileges we should tear down
the statues of our founding america as a
white supremacist terrible evil country
hopelessly bigoted
we've got to tear the whole thing down
the economic system the political system
and we've got to
to create a whole brand new country
that's very different than the martin
luther king vision the martin luther
king vision is america might have
problems but the the problems are only
so clear because we know the the idea of
america is so wonderful and america's
not living up to her ideals and we need
to we need to fulfill the promise of the
founding fathers and george washington
and thomas jefferson and and that vision
is completely at odds regardless of of
the left or the right trying to grab
martin luther king's legacy i think we
all have to acknowledge that the blm
version of american history is
completely at odds with the martin
luther king version and the blm version
is winning right now so biden was
probably right when he said that george
floyd had a greater impact on the world
that's unfortunate but probably the case
i'm so glad you liked that clip
i thought it was good work
i thought it was pretty interesting i
it's look i'm with you is what i'm
saying we both appreciated that clip so
you gotta subscribe
you gotta ring that bell get those
notifications for all the new videos
that come out and head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review i
appreciate it we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you